[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
[Applaus]
am 30 März 1896 fischt ein
Binnenschiffer bei reading etwa 65 km
westlich von London ein gut erhaltenes
Päckchen aus der Themse vielleicht hat
es ein Reisender verloren der auf einem
kleinen Boot und vermittelt in einer
Stromschnelle geraten ist oder es sind
die Liebesbriefe eines untreuen
Verehrers die eine um ihre Liebe
betrogene Frau enttäuscht und wütend von
einem Steg ins Wasser geworfen hat
vorsichtig öffnete er das durchweichte
Paket findet darin ein weiteres Päckchen
eingeschlagenen Geschenkpapier jetzt ist
seine Neugier endgültig geweckt er
schlägt das Papier zurück und
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland mein Name ist Stefan
Netzeband und ich bin Mirko Kasimir und
noch eine wichtige Warnung vorab es geht
heute um Morde an Neugeborenen der Mord
an Kindern ist ja so ziemlich das
abscheulichste was man sich vorstellen
kann und ihr solltet euch überlegen ob
ihr diese Episode wirklich hören wollt
wir werden uns mit Details zurückhalten
aber schon dass ihre Ausmaß der
Verbrechen über die wir heute reden
wollen macht die Geschichte schwer
erträglich es ist vielleicht ein kleiner
Trost dass diese Verbrechen 130 Jahre
zurückliegen und sich in dieser Form und
dieser Größenordnung heute sicherlich
nicht mehr wiederholen könnten und jetzt
Mirko erzähl gerne mal weiter in das
Geschenkpapier eingeschlagen ist die
winzige Leiche eines neugeborenen
Mädchens der Körper ist teilweise
verweht um ihren Hals ist ein Band
gewickelt und hinter dem linken Ohr
verknotet
die kleine Helena frei ist das letzte
von vermutlich mehreren hundert Opfern
von Emilia Geier eine der schlimmsten
massenmörderinnen aller Zeiten
Emilia deier wird 1837 in einem kleinen
Weiler in der Nähe von Bristol geboren
sie ist das jüngste von fünf Kindern und
sie hat Glück ihr Vater ist
schumachermeister und hat ein gutes ein-
und auskommen ihr bleibt die Armut
erspart sie ist wohl genährt um nicht zu
sagen ein bisschen zu dick hat gute
Kleidung sie liest gerne und entwickelt
eine große Liebe zu Poesie während
tausende ihre Altersgenossen 12 und mehr
Stunden am Tag in den neuen Fabriken
schuften müssen doch die glücklichen
Jahre Enden yeah ihre Mutter erkrankt an
Typhus und verliert nach und nach den
Verstand die kleine Emilia wird sie
pflegen bis sie im Jahr 1848 stirbt
die Menschen jener Zeit sind ständig vom
Tod umgeben schon 1841 da war Emilia
gerade vier ist an ihrer älteren
Schwester gestorben
1845 stirbt eine weitere Schwester
unmittelbar nach der Geburt doch der Tod
der Mutter und der Verfall den sie so
unmittelbar als ihre Pflegerin
miterleben muss haben sie besonders
getroffen
1859 stirbt auch ihr Vater Amelia
beginnt eine Ausbildung als
Krankenschwester als sie 24 Jahre alt
ist heiratet sie ihr Ehemann George
Thomas ist 35 Jahre älter als sie und
das ist schon eine naja ganze Menge vor
allem damals als ein Mann diesen Alters
nicht unbedingt erwarten konnte 80 Jahre
oder
älter zu werden die beiden schwindeln
auf der Heiratsurkunde um den Abstand
nicht so skandalös groß wirken zu lassen
der 59-Jährige George gibt sich als
48-Jähriger aus Emilia behauptet sie sei
35 die beiden haben ein gemeinsames Kind
doch 1869 acht Jahre nach der Geburt
stirbt ihr Ehemann
alleinerziehende Mutter das ist bis
heute eine verdammt harte Nummer in der
Vergangenheit erst recht hatten wir
übrigens auch mehrfach schon in dieser
Podcast-Reihe damals war das beinahe der
sichere Weg ins Elend Amelia daher
braucht dringend und ständig Geld am
besten leicht verdientes Geld und eine
Hebamme die sie während ihrer Arbeit als
Krankenschwester kennengelernt hat gibt
dir einen entscheidenden Tipp Baby
farming
Alter mir wird bei den Begriff schon
übel Baby farming aber eine damals weit
verbreitete Praxis das hatte natürlich
nichts mit Bauernhöfen Viehzucht und
Äckern zu tun aber durchaus mit einer
Art Ernte einer Ernte in Form von Geld
um das zu verstehen muss man wissen dass
so ziemlich das Übelste was einer Frau
damals passieren kann eine legitime
Schwangerschaft ist und diese Schicksal
trifft viele Frauen Liebe und
Sexualtrieb sind allemal und alle Zeit
stärker als gesellschaftliche Normen
zuverlässige Verhütung oder sichere
Abtreibung gibt es nicht und umso mehr
ungewollte Schwangerschaften und das
führt zu völliger gesellschaftliche
Ausgrenzung wenn es passiert den Frauen
bleibt wegen angeblicher Unmoral nicht
mal mehr der Weg ins Arbeitshaus
Arbeitshäuser waren etwas überspitzt
ausgedrückt fast so etwas wie
Gefängnisse mit Zwangsarbeit für arme
Menschen
eine Rettung vor dem Verhungern oder
einem Leben als Landstreicher oder
krimineller aber nicht einmal diese
Option steht den Müttern offen im
Prinzip stehen sie vor der Wahl sich zu
prostituieren zu verhungern oder Ihr
Baby auf die eine oder andere Art
loszuwerden
kindsmart durch die Mutter und es ist
schrecklich das zu sagen aber letztlich
kein großes Wunder ist unter diesen
Bedingungen kein seltenes Verbrechen
genaue Zahlen gibt es nicht da viele
solche Fälle mit den damaligen Mitteln
nicht aufgedeckt werden können und sehr
viele Babys und Kleinkinder ohnehin an
Krankheiten oder Mangelerscheinungen
sterben das Baby farming bietet in
gewisser Weise einen Ausweg und eine
Alternative zu den ziemlich übel
beleuchundeten weisenhäusern in denen
die Kinder ausgebeutet und oft
misshandelt werden heute würde man
wahrscheinlich von Pflegemittel
ansprechen gegen eine durchaus saftige
Gebühr von wenigstens zehn Pfund das
entspricht paar tausend Euro heute nimmt
die Pflegemutter das Kind bei sich auf
damals gibt es kein Jugendamt dass diese
praxis überwacht jeder oder eher jede
kann einfach in der Zeitung ihre Dienste
annoncieren ohne hintergrundcheck und
Registrierung das Angebot der
baby-fahrerinnen lautet also eigentlich
wir nehmen das Baby und später wenn ihr
eure Situation wieder im Griff habt zum
Beispiel indem ihr den Vater heiratet
dann holt ihr euch das Kind zurück oder
wir suchen eine liebevolle Familie die
ist adoptiert
es gibt den Bedarf und viele Kinder und
Mütter hat das sicher vor einem
schlimmen Schicksal bewahrt eine
sinnvolle Reaktion auf eine wirklich
üble Situation aber da ist so einfach
ist gibt es auch Frauen die hier eine
Möglichkeit sehen schnell an Geld zu
kommen und die die Kinder dann
vernachlässigen oder ihrerseits
ausbeuten
nach dem Tod ihres Mannes beginnt Amelia
daja Anzeigen zu platzieren sie
bezeichnet sich als respektable
verheiratete Frau Mütter die sich an Sie
wenden könnten in Zukunft ruhig schlafen
in dem Wissen dass Ihr Kind in einem
liebenden und sicheren zu Hause
aufwächst und damit beginnt ein
unfassbarer Horror der fast 30 Jahre
andauern wird und den vermutlich etwa
400 Kinder zum Opfer fallen
Amelia hat nämlich nie vor sich um die
Kinder zu kümmern sie will nicht farmen
sie will nur ernten sobald sie das Geld
erhalten und ein Baby an sich genommen
hat vernachlässigt sie ist mit voller
Absicht und um es ganz deutlich zu sagen
sie lässt die Kinder verhungern um sie
still zu halten gibt sie ihnen eine
Tinktur namens mother's friend deren
wirksamer Bestandteil wohl Opium ist und
von dem sie anscheinend selber ganz
gerne ein Schluck nimmt was ihr später
in einem bizarrentest das Leben retten
wird
Emilia daher zieht häufig um und nimmt
auch Kinder aus weit entfernten Städten
auf um Verdacht zu zerstreuen und
Nachfragen von Müttern aus dem Weg zu
gehen und sie versucht Ihrem Business
eine offizielle Legitimation zu geben
und scheinbar nach den Regeln zu spielen
wenn eins der Kinder aufgrund ihrer
Behandlung gestorben ist meldet sie den
Tod demörtlichen Corona oder einem Arzt
sie gewinnt schnell Routine darin die
schockierte und verzweifelte Trauernde
Pflegemutter zu spielen
1879 zehn Jahre nachdem ihr mörderisches
treiben begonnen hat wird ein Arzt
misstrauisch endlich muss man sagen
obwohl der Tod von Babys damals einen
alltägliches Ereignis ist hat er das
Gefühl ein bisschen zu oft zu dieser
Frau gerufen zu werden er meldet den
Behörden seinen Verdacht dass hier
jemand nachzuhelfen scheint im selben
Jahr wird Emilia daher verhaftet und
verurteilt und der Schrecken hat ein
Ende oder denkst Du ja Amelia daja wird
verhaftet ja sie wird wegen der
zahlreichen kindstode in ihrer Obhut
verurteilt zu sechs Monaten wegen
Vernachlässigung ist das krass auf jeden
Fall und es wird noch schlimmer nach der
Entlassung platziert sie sofort die
nächsten Anzeigen in Zeitungen und
bietet ihre Dienste und verzweifelten
Müttern ein sicheres liebevolles zu
Hause für ihre Kinder an sie hat gelernt
immer wieder schlüpft sie bei ihrer
inzwischen erwachsenen Tochter Polly
unterzieht noch häufiger als zuvor um
und nimmt an jedem neuen Ort eine neue
Identität an und nie wieder wird sie den
Tod eines Babys melden stattdessen
entsorgt sie die Leichen meist indem Sie
sie in die Themse wirft
bisher hat sie die Kinder durch
Vernachlässigung und Opium getötet um
einen natürlichen Tod vorzutäuschen
diese Vorsicht ist jetzt nicht mehr
nötig Emilia deier beginnt die ihr
anvertrauten Babys zu strangulieren oft
wenige Tage manchmal sogar wenige
Stunden nachdem eine Mutter sie bei ihr
abgegeben hat und ist damit schon wieder
bereit für das nächste unschuldige Opfer
und doch kommt man hier in den folgenden
Jahren einige Male beinahe auf die
Stiche doch sie kann sich jedes Mal den
Zugriff entwinden indem sie sich selbst
in ein Mentor Erteilung einweist heute
würde man das als psychiatrische Klinik
bezeichnen aber damals waren das
natürlich eher war Anstalten für
psychisch Kranke mit unsäglichen
Bedingungen sie täuscht eine
Geisteskrankheit vor und
Selbstmordgedanken wahrscheinlich hat
sie auch viel darüber gelernt als ihre
Mutter in Folge einer typhuserkrankung
den Verstand verloren hat einmal scheint
sie tatsächlich einen ernst gemeinten
Selbstmord versucht zu begehen erinnert
ihr euch dass ich erzählt habe dass ihr
Opium Missbrauch ihr das Leben retten
wird naja sie versucht sich mit einer
Überdosis umzubringen hat aber eine so
starke Toleranz gegen das Gift
entwickelt dass sie das überlebt sobald
sie befürchtet dass man ihr auf die
Schliche kommen könnte wechselt sie
wieder den Wohnort nimmt eine neue
Identität an und beginnt wieder anzeigen
zu veröffent oder auf Anzeigen von
Müttern zu antworten
im januar 1896 bringt die Barfrau
Evelina Mormon in sheltonham eine
uneheliche Tochter zur Welt Doris sie
sieht keinen anderen Weg als sie zur
Adoption freizugeben um weiter arbeiten
zu können also gibt Evelina eine Anzeige
in der Rubrik verschiedenste Zeitung
Bristol times in mirror auf in der sie
eine respektable Frau sucht die ihr
kleines Kind aufnimmt als die Annonce
erscheint fällt dir direkt daneben eine
andere Anzeige ins Auge aufgegeben
angeblich von einem kinderlosen Ehepaar
aus reading das ein Kind gegen eine
Gebühr von 10 Pfund adoptieren möchte
Eveline antwortet der Frau die sich
misses Harding nennt tatsächlich ist es
die aktuelle Tarnidentität von Amelia
daja Evelina marmen möchte lieber einen
kleinen wöchentlichen Betrag für die
Betreuung ihre Tochter zahlen
schließlich will Sie Doris sobald wie
möglich zu sich zurückholen misses
Harding besteht aber darauf den
einmaligen Betrag sofort und im
vorauszuhalten Evelina will nicht
schließlich ein ihr bleibt keine andere
Wahl und eine Woche später trifft muss
es Harding entschärfenheim ein
die junge Mutter ist von misses Hardings
bzw Dias fortgeschrittenem Alter und
ihrer stämmigen Erscheinung überrascht
aber daher sich daules gegenüber
liebevoll verhält übergibt sie ihre
Tochter eine Karton mit Kleidern und die
zehn Pfund
verzweifelt darüber dass sie sich nicht
mehr selber um ihre Tochter kümmern kann
begleitet Evelina da ja zum Bahnhof von
sheldenham und dann weiter nach Cluster
als gebrochene Frau kehrt sie in ihre
Wohnung zurück einige Tage später erhält
sie einen Brief und misses Harding in
dem steht das alles in Ordnung sei die
Mutter schreibt zurück er hält aber
keine Antwort
nichts ist in Ordnung daher bringt Doris
nicht überhaupt nach reading sondern in
die Mario road in Wille zu London wo
ihre 23-jährige Tochter Polly wohnt dort
findet daher ein weißes Band wie es zum
schneidern verwendet wird wickelt es
zweimal um den Hals des Babys und bindet
einen Knoten
später gibt daher zu dass sie die Kinder
gern beim Sterben beobachtet hat aber es
war bald vorbei mit ihnen da ja und ihre
Tochter wickeln die Leiche des Babys ein
sie behalten einen Teil der Kleidung die
die Mutter ihn mitgegeben hat der Rest
ist für den Pfandleiher bestimmt schon
am nächsten Tag bringt daher ein anderes
Kind namens Harry Simons in die my Road
daher findet kein weißes Band mehr und
benutzt das Band von Doris Leiche um den
13 Monate alten Jungen zu erwarten ich
weiß dass es jetzt eigentlich völlig
egal mit welchem Band Sie dieses Baby
ermordet aber manchmal sind es solche
Details die das ganze grauen eines
solchen falls irgendwie deutlich machen
diese Banalität diese praktischen
Erwägungen die man machen muss um so
massenhaft einfach kleine Kinder
umzubringen und sich sagte wir können ja
das Band von Doris noch mal nehmen das
ist ja noch gut wirklich schrecklicher
Fall ist das hier
dann packen ihre Tochter und ihre
Schwiegersohn beide Leichen in einen
Sack zusammen mit einigen Ziegelsteinen
um das Gewicht zu erhöhen daher fährt
nach reading an einem abgelegenen Ort in
der Nähe eines Wehrs bei cawasaki wirft
sie den Sack durch das Geländer in die
Tänzer
und dann am 30 März 1896 fast 30 Jahre
nachdem Amelia deier mit dem Baby
farming begonnen hat fischt ein Schiffer
ein Päckchen mit einer Babyleiche aus
der Themse
es ist die Leiche von Helena frei die
Amelia diher kurz vor Doris und Harry
ermordet hat eine Adresse die die
Behörden auf dem Packpapier entziffern
können führt sie endlich auf die Spur
der Mörderin doch noch können Sie Emilia
daher nicht mit dem Verbrechen in
Verbindung bringen also stellen Sie Ihr
eine Falle eine Anzeige wird aufgegeben
angeblich von einer Mutter die ihr Baby
abgeben will eine junge Frau wird als
Lockvogel angehört als ich Amelia da ja
mit ihr trifft schlagen die Polizisten
zu bei der Durchsuchung ihrer Wohnung
fällt als erstes ein durchdringender
Verwesungsgeruch auf dann finden Sie
Bänder die dem gleichen dass der kleinen
Helena frei um den Hals gewickelt war
außerdem Telegramme über
adoptionsvereinbarungen ausgeschnittene
anzeigen und die Herzen weichen den
Briefe von Müttern die nach ihren
Kindern Fragen endlich wird Emilia da ja
verhaftet und wegen Mordes angeklagt in
den den folgenden Wochen wird die Themse
nach weiteren Opfern abgesucht und die
Leichen von sechs Babys können geborgen
werden nur drei von ihnen werden
identifiziert darunter Harry Simons und
Doris marman man geht aufgrund ihres
modus-operandi der gefundenen Briefe und
weitere Quellen davon aus dass Emilia
deier in den 30 Jahren ihres grausamen
Treibens wenigstens 200 wahrscheinlich
aber eher 400 Kinder getötet hat vor
Gericht bekennt sie sich nur für einen
Mord schuldig und erklärt sich für
unzurechnungsfähig mit dem Hinweis auf
ihre zahlreichen Aufenthalte in asylen
für psychisch Kranke es hilft ihr nicht
die Geschworenen brauchen nur
viereinhalb Minuten Beratung dann
erklären Sie sie verschuldig am 10 juni
1896 wird Amelia da ja im Newgate prison
gehängt
Amelia diars Tochter Polly und ihr Mann
behaupten in ihrem späteren Prozess von
nichts gewusst zu haben und kommen damit
durch
es gibt einen kleinen Lichtblick in
dieser Geschichte die Morde die Emilia
diya begangen hat führen nämlich in den
folgenden Jahren zu Änderungen der
adoptionsgesetzgebung und auch zu einer
polizeilichen Überwachung dieser
sogenannten babyfarmen aber es wird noch
lange dauern bis der brutale Handel und
der Missbrauch von Babys aufhören ich
verweise übrigens hier noch mal auf den
Fall die engelmacherin wo das ganze auf
eine sehr sehr erschreckend ähnliche
Weise in Hamburg auf St Pauli gespielt
hat auf jeden Fall weiter in der
Geschichte zwei Jahre nach Amelia Dias
Hinrichtung wird in Newton Abit in Süd
Devin ein Baby unter dem Sitz eines
Eisenbahnwagons gefunden das drei Wochen
alte Kind ist in braunes Papier ein
gewickelt es ist unterkühlt und
erschöpft aber es lebt eine verzweifelte
junge Mutter Jane Hill hat es für 12
Pfund an eine misses Stewart übergeben
die angebliche Mr holt das Baby im
plymout ab und versteckt es im nächsten
besten Zug unter dem Sitz misses ist in
Wahrheit niemand anderes als Polly die
Tochter von Emilia Geier die Tochter der
babymörderin hat das grausame Handwerk
ihrer Mutter fortgeführt sie wird zu
zwei Monaten Zwangsarbeit wegen
aussetzen eines Kindes verurteilt
[Musik]
für die Geschichte der mörderischen
baby-farmerin Amelia deier haben wir auf
Beiträge von BBC co- UK orders
interesting.com und get reading.com
sowie die Folge the demon Baby Pharma
des Podcasts dark history
zurückgegriffen wir danken euch fürs
zuhören und auch für die zahlreichen
Nachrichten und fallvorschläge die uns
erreicht haben vielen Dank dafür und bis
zur nächsten Episode von Tatort
Deutschland euer Mirko und euer Stefan